this is a floater there's now the pickup
Grizzly's a chance for the lead
[Applause]
[Music]
and I think he can see all the pieces
grand
mid-range athletic enough to finish it
under love Rosa back out and here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you play long enough a no look out to
Tucker
take it away Moran
[Applause]
Wow
Wow it gives them the tribbles ooh brain
calling for it gets it and it goes up
with a thunderous leaped hand over the
top of Paul George because I felt like
if he would attack
Fitz's do they all get one
[Applause]
stop blocking teeth they put everybody
in the basket on this
Danny Green you could get a little taste
JaVale McGee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
basketball
bring the bed look at this split the gap
between the legs
oh good the floater there's
pick up British leaves a chance for the
lead
[Applause]
Jersey's in front
oh yeah
[Music]
it'll be
up against O'Neill they'll get it to
Brandon Brandon with two on the clock
for the win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can forego a salami you can put back
down to fill me with Joe Eagles on me I
can feel it's in my foot and elevate
here come the pelicans up one they go to
Williams and facing up and
the clock ticking down exactly knew how
much time he had great use of the
dribble
[Applause]
he's got to keep doing this right now I
just gotta say
chris boucher here's the
whose Boucher is going to challenge
every shot he's gonna challenge
everybody that comes in the pan
what up at you boy Adam left coach you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report